hi there steve kaufman here um i haven't
done a video in a long time i feel a bit
guilty so i've decided to do one
i got my cross-country skiing
shirt on here
it's been warm but i went in for a swim
in the ocean and uh it was pretty chilly
in there uh
uh bracing
maybe 17 degrees
celsius i'm not sure quite how cool but
it sure cools you off so
sitting here in the evening i got my
extra little thin sweatshirt over my
t-shirt
today i want to talk about efficiency in
language learning
and because i've been thinking about
what you know my learning activities
here in czech
uh i started czech about five weeks ago
uh i've been working primarily at link i
did find some material at home
an old phrase book which i listened to
you know i find once you get going in a
language you tend to buy things i was in
a bookstore i saw this small
book on learning czech i don't have it
around here but it was actually
from a group called the hippocrene books
it's beginners check with two audio cds
so i went through that
and so i had an interesting sort of um
you know
observation on the one hand if i listen
to the easy content in this
uh beginner's check
and they read the text once
at normal speed and they read it very
very slowly and then they record all the
vocabulary and you can listen to that
and of course the first time you listen
to it
it's wonderful to be able to understand
everything because most of my listening
um i guess has been divided into two
types i have the kind of material that
has been created by our members at link
most of which is i would say half of
which is easy in half which is not easy
and then i've been listening to radio
praha radio praha
and i've been listening to this
audiobook the good soldier
and of course the radio braha is
difficult the soldier's good soldiers
break is also very difficult but i have
texts for that so i read it on link i
save my links i can review them on my
ipad i can sit down and go over them in
in ilink many many times and then i
listen when i go running and so all of
this is just kind of letting all the
language wash over me occasionally
reviewing them in flashcards so and i've
been doing mostly that and plus also
reading uh
this czech newspaper which i have online
here which i go to every day and read
i use the the link bookmarklet to bring
in
this is uh
novini
and so here's an article
conference
marzenic
fondue i understand that all and i read
the article and there's words that i
don't understand but they want to
unblock the
frozen funds and so forth
but
and that's just text that i read but i
find now that i'm able to read these
newspaper articles
you know not too bad i
you know my my text and link is covered
in yellow highlighted words because
these are words that i've looked up and
i'm seeing again and again and again and
they're gradually starting to stick
but in radio praha when i listen to
those articles even though i've read
them and saved the words and studied
them when i hear it you know i
understand 30 40
so when i got back to this uh check for
beginners whatever it was here with two
the cds the hippocrene books of course i
understood just about everything but
there were still a few words that i
didn't understand and then i would read
the text
and i'd ah now i understand yeah it's
that word i didn't quite make it out
when i was listening and i listen again
i still miss it
so then i started saying to myself am i
better off to spend a lot of time trying
to nail down everything and that's in
these 10
lessons in this beginner book or am i
better off to continue
listening to radio praha reading the
transcripts saving the words and phrases
going off to the uh
the czech newspaper jessica novini
and reading more articles about vatslav
krauss and his latest outrageous
statements or whatever
and
doing a bit of
fake and just letting the words wash
over me
because on the one hand doing that
has seen my vocabulary really really
increased to where i i feel that i've
done i've achieved greater progress in
czech
in five weeks than i can remember in any
other language now it helps that i did
russian the structure is very similar
the vocabulary is surprisingly
you know 50
russian or similar to russian 50 quite
different
uh
so and then in the end i ended up saying
to myself you know it's very satisfying
to try to nail stuff down
listen to this
uh this video here or this video this
audio cd here
and listen and listen and listen until i
nail down every word and i nailed on
every expression and i listened to it
over and over
but at the end of doing that i haven't
learned many words
because i know most the words in this
book
this whole beginner book basically i'm
there you know there aren't many words
that i don't know even though i don't
necessarily pick them up every time when
i listen
so i you know i kind of think you need
to do a bit of both
so i don't mind doing a bit of the
simple uh whatever listening to it a few
times it helps pick up on some
pronunciation issues it helps pick up on
some structural issues but i'm inclined
to spend more and more of my time simply
exposing myself to the language to
interesting content
uh
linking it seeing the number of yellow
words increase and of course in link the
yellow it's a dark yellow and as you
know a little better it becomes a
lighter yellow and then a lighter yellow
still
i think that process is bringing me more
words and is bringing me more
familiarity with the language
and so and then i remember when i
studied chinese i
basically convinced myself that the most
important thing in language learning was
efficiency
because efficiency means intensity the
more efficiently you learn the more
intense your learning is and i felt back
40 years ago when i was studying chinese
that and i did my chinese
did the british foreign service exam
whatever in after nine months of study
the other people took two years but i
did it you know completely like a
fanatic i was at it five six seven eight
hours a day and i felt that i learned it
better because i did it so much more
intensely than these other students who
were taking their time at it and so i
got hung up really started thinking
about efficiency i developed my
efficient way of learning characters
what i thought was an efficient way of
of learning the language which was to
ignore the grammar explanations which
was to
notice the patterns and get enough
content in me that these patterns start
to become natural this is my way of
becoming efficient in chinese
so talking about efficiency
uh when i think of what i did had to do
when i started with russian and link
three four years ago was so slow and
clunky and at times it took seven eight
ten seconds to save you know go to the
dictionary get the meaning bring it back
and now it's all there with a mouse over
like link itself has become so much more
efficient
and so therefore in the older less
efficient link i did relatively more
listening because if a is easier to do
it was more pleasant because it was a
bit of a chore to save links in link
whereas now i find myself doing more and
more reading in link because i'm able to
cover interesting content
it's that challenge of reading something
new and interesting i still listen when
i go running i listen when i'm in my car
but i'm doing relatively more
reading so i mean everybody is gonna
it's gonna depend on what you like what
you like to do but i find it quite
efficient
to go after
new content
especially if i'm familiar with a
context because it's almost easier to
understand something that talks about i
don't know
libya and and the meeting in paris about
libya
where you understand the context then to
read some artificial content that's been
written about so and so visiting their
newfound friends in prague and and what
they're having for dinner and all kinds
of the names of the czech dishes and
stuff which is it's too early for me
i'll worry about that when i get to
prague and i want to order something in
a restaurant
so
i think it's more efficient again to
focus on content of interest meaningful
content and to push yourself to acquire
more and more words and to allow these
words and phrases and structures to
become natural through a lot of exposure
with link maybe sliding a bit more
towards the reading that i have done in
the past
and then occasionally to go back to
something very simple to kind of get
some grounding in some very basic
structure very basic vocabulary that you
might have maybe
not you know
really
you know learned as properly as you
could have on the first or second pass
over so
just a general rant here on this whole
issue of efficiency and also to update
you on my
check learning
i'm going to continue my input input
activities in check and perhaps in a
month or so maybe start talking and and
see where i end up after after three
months see if i'm able to hold up my end
of the conversation uh in a few months
from now so
thank you for listening bye for now